in good shape your weekly dose of health
information on deutsche welle find out
more about what's new in medical
treatment alternative medicine as well
as nutrition wellness and beauty medical
professionals therapists and counselors
are in our studio to offer their expert
advice on in good shape with me in the
studio now is Professor Malik bash Bosh
berlin-based psychiatrist who's area of
expertise is being happy what a nice
thing to spend your days on welcome to
the studio hello happiness is a very
individual thing is there a general
definition of being happy now there are
thousands of definitions about the term
well-being happiness but not not a
single one on which all scientists can
agree I would say it is a predisposition
which guides you through live in an
optimistic manner and there's some kind
of short-lived moments of happiness and
long lasting happiness and what are the
differences you can see the differences
on a neurobiological level so if you
look into the brain what is happening if
you have a short lasting episode of
happiness or lack or leg lasting you see
on the one hand the short lasting that
certain neurotransmitters such as
dopamine are being released and the long
lasting things other networks like the
prefrontal cortex are being active so
it's not just in our mind it's in our
bodies as well and research has shown
that happier people are generally
healthier people why is that it is well
known that if you're optimistic if
you're happy that you have a certain
degree of healthiness so you have a
reduced risk of cardiovascular diseases
you have a reduced risk of getting skin
disorders a reduced risk of getting
depression obviously so that has been
well observed and you can track it down
to the molecular level so there are
certain molecules which are different in
happy people and does this affect our
life expectancy as well yeah that's one
of the most surprising thing so if
you're an optimistic person you live
approximately
to ten years longer and that even
studies which indicate that making
everyone happy would have the same
effect like deleting all cancer diseases
but it's not just the decision to be
happy I mean if you're a medically
person and it's hard for you just to
turn the switch and save from nowaday I
will be happier I see a trick no you
come on earth it was a certain
predisposition so it's not like that
everything is influenced by the
environment but the good news is that
you can influence your genes by a rental
factors so the classical example would
be people who were regularly Sox in the
age between 0 & 3 they will change a
gene which is responsible for thermo
sensitivity which make them people who
are very very spawn civ to coldness
afterwards what role do you think
exercise place and happiness um it is
one road towards some happiness the
reason is it is something which brings
people into contact where you do
something for yourself and where you
force yourself to focus your thoughts on
certain things and all these elements
usually make make one happy okay there's
an Eric proverb that says instead of
complaining that the rose bush has
thorns be happy that the thorn bush has
roses didn't I say that's a very nice
thing which shows the basic assumption
one has to make that we are surrounded
by by very positive things and many of
us usually see the negative things and
do not focus on positive things which is
one main road towards a very optimistic
and well life so can we all learn to be
happier just by pretending being happy
for instance yeah there are certain
feedback mechanisms so if you force
yourself to do things which you enjoy
you will feel um will have positive
emotions and by that you will sure that
your surrounding and then you will get
positive feedback from your surrounding
and then you get in a very very
positive circle the same is true for the
negative side too but it is doable for
the positive emotion side too when I go
into a bookstore to the self-help books
and I I've got the feeling that there's
something like modern compulsion and
being happy and that I need to be happy
and that I'm not allowed to be sad and
is it the right thing to live no and
even for that there are a couple of
studies which indicate that if you have
permanently positive emotion the decrees
of happiness and well-being decreases
was increasing number of positive things
so you need from time to time phases
where you have negative emotions there
your melancholic and being forced to be
optimistic this rather than thing which
makes you pessimistic yeah and when do
physicians diagnose a depression so and
that's not just being a phase of being
sad but it's really a disease the very
clear criteria need a couple of symptoms
such as a loss of energy negative mood
and that for a time period for at least
two weeks and then one can speak of a
depression okay and then you have to go
to a doctor and to treat it yes okay
we've got some viewer questions from
Canada edinboro primo em says she's got
a friend and the friend invited her to
visit some laughter classes so it's a
group of people who laugh together is
that might be a way so nothing for
patients obviously but for healthy
people and we talk about this positive
feedback mechanisms and being surrounded
by by people doing something together
listening to positive emotion mighty do
something in the very death of your
brain okay and what's your personal tip
for being happy so on why I use such a
happy person you should take from time
to time a bird's eye view and do not
take things too seriously so that will
be my very simple trick and you really
can make it through the day with that so
so you do this from time to time it's
difficult but it is I try and it works
quite well so happiness is the thing you
need to train yes okay thank you so much
for being with us and distant relatives
thank you
you